chaque spectateur en raison du sujet
traité dans cette vidéo youtube a décidé
de la démonétisé au motif que son
contenu n'est pas adapté aux annonceurs
malgré mes requêtes et en dépit de son
caractère éducatif rien à faire cette
vidéo ne me rapportera rien oui c'est
injuste mais que voulez vous c'est comme
ça comme il est hors de question que je
sens sur ma vidéo pour la rendre
conforme aux attentes des annonceurs
j'ai décidé de la publier tel quel sans
la monétisation néanmoins si vous
souhaitez soutenir mon travail et
m'encourager à continuer vous pouvez le
faire en me laissant une pièce sur tipi
ou sur tout autre plate forme de
donation dont vous trouverez les liens
en descriptions et en partageant
massivement cette vidéo sur vos réseaux
sociaux
sachant que youtube n'a aucun intérêt à
mettre en avant les vidéos non monétiser
puisqu'elle ne leur rapporte rien autant
vous le demander directement à vous qui
êtes les premiers garants de ma
visibilité sur ce je vous remercie et
vous souhaite un bon visionnage
bonjour à tous on se retrouve
aujourd'hui pour une nouvelle vidéo je
vais m'attaquer à un sujet assez
sensible la pornographie donc je ne suis
pas venu tout seul je suis venu
accompagné de toutes mes notes de tous
les documents sur lesquels je vais
m'appuyer dans cette vidéo on va prendre
le temps d'aller au fond du sujet on se
retrouve tout de suite après générique
c'est parti
[Musique]
alors avant que les premiers
commentaires ne fuse je précise tout de
suite que je ne vais pas aborder la
question de la pornographie sous un
angle moral tout simplement parce que ça
ne me regarde pas ça ne m'intéresse pas
je m'en moque totalement chacun fait
absolument ce qu'il veut donc tout
argument qui consistera à me dire que
critiquer la pornographie c'est être un
réactionnaire un conservateur ou je ne
sais quoi bien ça tombe à l'eau ça ne
fonctionnera pas parce qu'ici je vais
m'appuyer sur des données factuelles des
données concrètes scientifique toutes
les sources on tente description de la
vidéo j'afficherai également au fur et à
mesure les captures d'écran pour que
vous puissiez aller vérifier et faire
vos propres recherches sur tout ce que
je dirai donc avant d'entrer dans le vif
du sujet je vous demanderai de partager
au maximum cette vidéo autour de vous
sur vos réseaux sociaux pour que le plus
de personnes possibles soit informée sur
ce sujet complexe parfois tabou qu'est
la pornographie et j'en profite aussi
pour remercier pour rendre hommage au
travail de boris il a réalisé une vidéo
très complexe sur le sujet dont je me
suis en partie inspiré je vous invite à
aller la voir le lien est dans la
description
donc on y va c'est parti j'organisais ma
vidéo en cinq points principaux
et je vous invite à rester jusqu'à la
fin parce que vous allez voir on va y
aller crescendo premier point quelque
chose que vous savez tous mais qu'il est
important de rappeler le porno est
d'abord une industrie la pornographie
c'est d'abord de l'économie c'est une
économie à ses juteuses sans vouloir
faire de jeu de mots puisque ça rapporte
environ 10 milliards de dollars par an
et 90 % la production pornographique
vient des états unis n'oublions pas que
s'il n'y avait pas de commerce de la
pornographie
il n'y aurait pas de pornographie donc
avant de dire que la pornographie c'est
une forme d'art cinématographique ou je
ne sais quoi
non la pornographie c'est d'abord une
économie autre chiffre intéressant il
faut savoir que entre 25 et 35 % des
requêtes tapées sur internet sont en
relation avec du contenu pornographique
ce qui veut dire que plus d'un tiers de
ce que l'on recherche dans le monde sur
internet
c'est du sexe voilà ce rappel est en
fait on passe maintenant au deuxième
point le porno est basé sur la
marchandisation du corps humain donc ce
deuxième point est évidemment en lien
avec le premier
si le porno est une économie c'est
évidemment l'économie du corse et
l'instrumentaliser
son du cor et c'est une
instrumentalisation qui est basée sur la
plus grande ressource disponible dans le
monde une ressource illimitée à savoir
le désirent dites vous bien qu'un
individu homme de sa puberté jusqu'à sa
mort est en capacité de ressentir du
désir sexuel
si maintenant vous multipliez ça par le
nombre d'hommes qui ont accès à internet
sur terre et que vous multipliez ce
résultat par le nombre d'orgasmes que
peut avoir un homme par jour bien vous
obtenez un chiffre assez énorme
donc comme le rappelait borie dans sa
vidéo ce sont les hommes qui se font le
plus facilement mener à la braguette et
de ce fait il n'y a rien d'étonnant à ce
que la pornographie soit le plus souvent
la représentation de fantasmes masculins
ce qui nous permettra de mieux
comprendre pourquoi la femme est
instrumentalisé pourquoi la femme et
objective et dans les films
pornographiques
en cela la pornographie c'est d'abord la
mise en scène à des fins d'excitation
sexuelle de l'avilissement des femmes
et peu importe que les femmes qui jouent
dans ces films soient consentantes
puisque la notion de consentement c'est
d'abord une notion juridique c'est une
notion sur laquelle repose un contrat
donc oui on peut consentir à être
déshumanisé on peut consentir à être
humilié avilit publiquement on peut même
consentir à la torture on peut même
consentir à sa propre mort puisque
rappelez vous ce fait divers dans lequel
un homme a posé une petite annonce dans
laquelle il demandait à être assassinée
ça fait partie des choses auxquelles on
peut consentir c'est vrai mais ce n'est
pas parce qu'il ya consentement qu'il
n'y a pas d humanisation et entendons
nous bien le problème n'est pas ici
moral puisque après tout chacun fait ce
qu'il veut dans le cadre de son intimité
le problème est que la pornographie est
destiné à être exposé à être représentés
publiquement en paix mais les pratiques
sexuelles extrêmes on peut avoir envie
de faire des choses hors du commun dans
le cadre de son intimité sexuelle mais
ne soyons pas naïfs
la représentation de ce type de
fantasmes a d'abord une visée économique
tout simplement parce qu'elle s'adresse
au plus bas instincts de l'homme et tout
le monde sait que si on met un cul sur
une affiche ça va forcément attirer
l'attention
le problème je disais ne concerne pas
les pratiques sexuelles extrêmes ou
déviante qui relève du libre choix de
chacun
le problème réside dans la
représentation publique dans
l'accessibilité au public de pratique
qui relève d'abord du cadre privé c'est
la distinction que faisait le philosophe
nietzsche entre d'un côté le dionysiaque
qui est le monde de l'irrationnel
monde de l'animalité de la pulsion de
l'instinct et le monde de la pole il ya
un qui est le monde du rationnel du sens
des règles des cadres et à partir du
moment où on mélange ces deux mondes que
sont le dionysiaque hélas paulinien on
est dans la confusion totale des genres
et on est forcément dans la perturbation
des repères la pornographie c'est
littéralement la représentation de la
prostitution
et lorsqu'on parle de quelque chose
d'obscène obscène veut dire en dehors de
la scène ce qui est en dehors de la
scène c'est ce qui n'est pas censé être
représenté ce qui n'est pas censé à être
exposée aux yeux du public et notamment
de nos enfants or le problème
vous le voyez arriver c'est que de fait
la pornographie aujourd'hui n'est plus
un domaine séparer n'est plus un domaine
réservé aux adultes c'est quelque chose
qui peut être accessible à n'importe qui
à partir du moment où on a une connexion
internet
nos enfants vos enfants auront accès à
la pornographie
évidemment ils ne vous diront pas ils
n'iront pas se vanter de consulter des
images pornographiques sur internet
mais dites vous bien qu'à partir du
moment où ils sont en âge de se servir
d'un smartphone ils sont en âge d'aller
consulter des sites pornographiques et
ils le font ils le font entre copains
ils le font dans la cour de récréation
ils le font dans leur chambre
quand vous n'êtes pas là où quand vous
êtes en train de dormir ils le font
quand ils le souhaitent et vous savez
très bien que pour accéder à un site
pornographique
il suffit simplement de répondre à la
question avez vous plus de 18 ans donc
je peux vous dire que même à 13 ou 14
ans c'est pas ça qui va vous dissuader
donc à ceux qui me diront la
pornographie a toujours existé c'est pas
quelque chose de nouveau donc ce n'est
pas quelque chose dont il faut
s'inquiéter
je réponds oui la pornographie a
toujours existé mais les supports
pornographiques qui existait dans
l'antiquité qui existait au moyen-âge ou
dans les années 50 n'ont absolument rien
à voir avec les supports pornographiques
actuelle puisque ces supports visuels
étaient statiques
c'est à dire qu'il consistait dans des
images des gravures ou des dessins alors
que les films pornographiques sont
dynamiques c'est à dire qu'il met en
scène des représentations en mouvement
de l'acte sexuel
les représentations statique de la
sexualité comme les vieux magazines tels
que clés ball par exemple ont pour effet
de faire fonctionner l'imagination de
celui qui les regarde l'image est un
support mais l'imagination doit faire
son travail pour qu'on puisse atteindre
l'excitation alors qu'avec les sites
pornographiques aujourd'hui non
seulement vous avez des images en
mouvement vous avez des séquences
filmées avec d'innombrables plans de
caméras qui sont autant d'occasions pour
le cerveau de trouver une excitation
lorsque vous regardez un film porno
votre cerveau est beaucoup plus impliqué
il est beaucoup plus engagés dans ce que
vous regardez que lorsque vous regardez
une carte postale avec une femme nue
donc oui la pornographie existe depuis
toujours mais ce qui n'existe pas depuis
toujours c'est le mode de diffusion
dynamique de la pornographie que permet
internet sachant qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes encore devant un écran mais que
très prochainement l'écran va être
remplacé par le casque de réalité
virtuelle dans lequel votre cerveau est
incapable de faire la différence entre
la fiction et la réalité le cerveau
réagit à ce que vous voyez il réagit un
environnement sensoriel et le casque de
réalité virtuelle va permettre une
immersion sensorielle absolument totale
qui fait que votre cerveau ne va rien
comprendre à ce qui lui arrive
le cerveau humain n'est pas conçu il
n'est pas prévu pour recevoir un flot
d'image pornographique aussi important
car vous le verrez c'est un point que
nous allons aborder plus tard dans cette
vidéo pour le cerveau les images que
vous lui envoyez sont la réalité
donc quand on voit le déversement
ininterrompue d'image pornographique sur
internet
quand on sait que certains sites
pornographiques contiennent plusieurs
millions de vidéos à caractère sexuel on
est loin de la rubrique lingerie du
catalogue printemps été de la redoute
c'est ce qui nous fait arriver au
troisième point de cette vidéo
le porno influence la jeunesse donc j'ai
il faut savoir que la moitié des
adolescents de 15 à 17 ans reconnaissent
avoir déjà consulté un site
pornographique
donc ça ça ne concerne que ceux qu'ils
admettent on imaginait la proportion
réelle et 14 ans et l'âge moyen auquel
un adolescent admet avoir consulté un
site pornographique pour la première
fois et ce qui est intéressant c'est que
parmi les adolescents interrogés
la plupart ont dit qu'il se considérait
eux mêmes trop jeune pour regarder de la
pornographie et il juge après coup que
cette expérience était prématuré mais
l'influencé de la pornographie sur la
jeunesse ne se limite pas à la
consultation des sites pornographiques
mais à la manière dont la pornographie
influence la culture et notamment la
culture des adolescents la pornographie
influence la mode elles influencent le
cinéma mais aussi la culture musicale
retrouve l'influencé de la pornographie
dans les clips notamment dans les clips
de rap mais aussi dans l'hyper
sexualisation de nombreuses chanteuses
qui représentent des modèles de féminité
aujourd'hui pour les adolescentes donc
l'influencé de la pornographie ne se
limite pas à la consultation de sites
pornographiques
elle se répand dans toute la culture
populaire
à travers des codes une esthétique et un
langage au viguier a très bien décrit ce
phénomène dans une émission dont vous
trouverez le lien en descriptions le
porno influence la jeunesse ils
influencent nos représentations ils
influencent nos codes sociaux culturels
et linguistiques mais il ya plus grave
encore est ce le quatrième point de
cette vidéo
le porno a un impact direct sur le
cerveau alors là on va rentrer dans les
choses un petit peu sérieuse à tous ceux
qui vous diront que la pornographie n'a
aucun impact négatif sur la santé à tous
ceux qui vous diront qu'il ne faut pas
exagérer qu'il ne faut pas dramatiser
que la pornographie n'a jamais fait de
mal à personne de figurez-vous que des
études scientifiques ont été menées qui
tendent à démontrer un impact négatif de
la pornographie sur le cerveau la
consultation régulière d'image
pornographique provoquerait un
ralentissement de l'activité cérébrale
et une diminution partielle de ce qu'on
appelle la matière grise pour être plus
précis une exposition fréquente à du
contenu pornographique engendrerait une
diminution de la taille du striatum une
structure nerveuses situées sous le
cortex cérébral comment cela est il
possible me demanderez-vous eh bien
lorsque vous consulter du contenu
pornographique votre cerveau soumis à
l'excitation libère une hormone la
dopamine
évidemment c'est mathématique plus vous
allez consulter d'image pornographique
plus vous allez être soumis à
l'excitation et plus votre cerveau va
libérer cette hormone du plaisir la
dopamine
au point de provoquer un dérèglement de
ce qu'on appelle le système de la
récompense le système de la récompense
c'est très simple à comprendre
c'est ce qui dans notre cerveau va faire
qu'on associe un geste ou une action à
un plaisir à une sensation agréable donc
à une récompense c'est ce qu'on utilise
par exemple pour le dressage de certains
animaux on va donner un sucre un chien
parce qu'il aura obéi et donc on va
l'inciter à reproduire le même geste
on va donner du poisson à une otarie qui
aura fait ce qu'on lui demande et donc
le système de la récompense c'est tout
simplement cette fonction cérébrale qui
associe une action à un plaisir et ce
qui se produit quand on regarde
régulièrement des images pornographiques
c'est que le système de la récompense
est activé en permanence et donc le
cerveau se retrouve totalement inondée
de dopamine ils se retrouvent inondées
de plaisir et ne comprend pas ce qui lui
arrive puisque normalement la sensation
plaisir c'est le résultat d'un certain
effort puisque précisément il n'ya de
récompenses que lorsqu'il y a eu un
effort pour obtenir cette récompense
c'est ce que le philosophe jacques
derrida a appelé la
ans différence avec un a c'est à dire
que le plaisir est toujours différée par
rapport à l'effort qui permet d'obtenir
ce plaisir donc pour en revenir au
système de la récompense est à
l'altération de l'activité cérébrale
dites vous bien que la surstimulation
que provoque l'exposition massive à du
contenu pornographique va avoir pour
effet de détruire progressivement vos
connexions neuronales et va complètement
fragilisé votre centre de la décision ce
qui va avoir pour effet mécanique une
baisse de la motivation
une diminution de l'énergie une
diminution de la volonté une baisse de
la libido aussi voir un risque
d'impuissance puisqu'une sur stimulation
par la pornographie va altérer vos
récepteurs sensoriels va vous
désensibiliser en quelque sorte et c'est
ce qui va donner chez de nombreux
consommateurs de pornographie un
ramollissement de la volonté une baisse
du caractère une baisse de l'énergie une
perte générale de l'envié une tendance à
l'isolément à la procrastination une
fatigue chronique et plus vous allez
être à la recherche d'image extrême
d'image de plus en plus choquantes tout
simplement parce qu'il existe ce qu'on
appelle la neuroplasticité et que le
cerveau s'adapte et se conforme à ce que
vous lui fait subir
voilà pourquoi plus vous allez être
exposés à du contenu abêtissant voir
abrutissant et plus vous allez perdre
vos facultés intellectuelles que vous
allez perdre vos capacités cognitives
aux capacités de réflexion dont vous
voyez qu'on aurait tort de prendre à la
légère ce problèmes de la pornographie
chez les jeunes et ça me conduit
maintenant à mon cinquième et dernier
point le porno a pour finalité la
masturbation
on va sortir de l'hypocrisie et
reconnaître que la pornographie est
d'abord quelque chose qui est fait par
les hommes pour les hommes en vue d'une
jouissance sexuelle solitaire ce n'est
pas moi qui le dit c'est l'actrice
pornographique tiffany hopkins qui a
déclaré la finalité de la pornographie
c'est la masturbation la masturbation
est une étape dans la découverte par
l'adolescent de sa sexualité et il ne
s'agit en aucun cas d'émettre un
quelconque jugement moral sur cette
pratique par contre il faut être
conscient que comme le tabac comme
l'alcool ou la drogue
la masturbation et la pornographie
peuvent avoir un caractère addictif
lorsqu'un adolescent éprouve le besoin
d'aller quotidiennement sur un site
pornographique et de se masturber c'est
qu'il y a un problème ça signifie que
son système de la récompense est
déréglée sassi
fille qu'il est en train d'instaurer une
confusion dans son cerveau entre la
réalité et la fiction et ça ça va le
conduire dans un cercle vicieux où pour
échapper à la frustration de la réalité
quotidienne
il va se réfugier dans les images
pornographiques et progressivement son
cerveau va s'adapter à cette nouvelle
réalité virtuelle donc à cette réalité
qui n'en est pas une
ce qui va avoir un impact négatif dans
l'ensemble de sa vie sociale
sentimentale et scolaire un adolescent
ou jeune adulte qui est dépendant qui
est accro à la pornographie à la
masturbation est un adolescent qui est
en train de jeter totalement son énergie
par la fenêtre qui est en train de
gaspiller toutes ses ressources et pluie
gaspille race en énergie et moins il
aura envie d'entreprendre mois il aura
envie de réussir - les choses auront
d'importance à ses yeux et ça ça peut
être la cause d'un isolement social d'un
échec scolaire ou d'une frustration
sentimentale
si tu regarde cette vidéo et que tu es
dans cette situation je t'encourage
immédiatement à arrêter toute cette
merde tu vas beaucoup mieux à faire dans
ta vie que de tirer le manche pendant
des heures devant des femmes que tu ne
rencontrera jamais donc si tu as la
frustration investi cette frustration
dans quelque chose de productif métaux
sport inscris toi à la salle va faire du
roller va courir va faire du foot avec
tes potes mais toi la musique mais toi
la photo fait des vidéos fait tout ce
que tu veux mais fait quelque chose de
productif fait quelque chose dont tu
pourras être fiers fait quelque chose
qui va occuper ton esprit et ont tant
fait quelque chose qui a de la valeur
quant à vous parents qui avaient des
adolescents prenez conscience que ce
problème en est un noeud sur dramatiser
pas le problème et n'essayez pas de
confondre votre enfant si vous le
soupçonner de consulter des sites
pornographiques
le but n'est surtout pas de l'humilier
ou de le faire culpabiliser ça
n'arrangera absolument rien sachez que
le problème n'est pas irréversible
puisque la neuroplasticité du cerveau
fait qu'il est très bien capable de se
reprogrammer de se réadapter et qu'à
partir du moment où on arrête de
consulter du porno il suffit de quelques
jours éventuellement de quelques
semaines pour que tout se remette en
ordre
voilà ce que j'ai à vous dire soyez
vigilants soyez attentifs et fait au
mieux dans l'intérêt de votre enfant
voilà cette vidéo est à présent terminée
je vous remercie de l'avoir suivi
jusqu'au bout n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner de me rejoindre sur facebook et
sur instagram et un grand merci à toutes
les personnes qui me soutiennent sur
type est un grand merci à vous deux
du coeur je vous dis à bientôt pour une
prochaine vidéo et d'ici là soyez sages
[Musique]